[Musique]
on applaudit alors vraiment là on a le
goût de connaître tous
moi je vous connais un peu lui vous
connaît encore mieux et tout le monde va
apprendre à vous connaître au cours des
prochaines prochaine 9 45 minutes on
pourra pas aller plus loin mais on a des
jeunes personnalités ou sur autour de la
table et je vais expliquer maintenant à
se joindre à nous sinon il est question
bienvenue à tam tam canada édition
spéciale en direct du palais des congrès
de montréal
aujourd'hui vendredi bien on a le
plaisir d'être au quatrième à la
quatrième édition du salon magro canado
maghrébin du développement et ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'on est ici c'est
pour nous une occasion de se joindre à
la mission de ce salon qui est de faire
valoir le talent la jeunesse et puis le
développement dans la communauté
maghrébine la can à douma gatti à
montréal notamment fois on va donner des
chiffres
j'ai reçu sa de vos documents adele qui
est l'organisateur du salon canal aux
maghrébins il y avait seulement 38 mille
personnes maghrébine au québec en 1996
et là on est rendu à 300 mais
probablement
en 2018 toi et pour le québec c'est une
immigration de choix ce sont des gens en
général qui s'exprime bien en français
donc c'est toutes les occasions ici pour
les gens de collaborer ensemble de
travailler au développement de la
société dans lesquelles on se trouve
présentement alors je présente tout le
monde vous levez la main sans faire
tomber les microphones tout de même dès
que je vous présente d'accord on va
commencer par adel achouri organisateurs
du salon canada ou maghrébins
fantastique on l'applaudît en l1 et vous
allez continuer à vous à plusieurs vous
même
alors on a c'est le matin au chu bennani
du conseil des montréalaises et reda
agourram
ah là là c'est un nom bien connu du
rapport pourquoi tout de suite on va le
dire l'accord ex footballeur de l'équipe
de l'impact de montréal et vous êtes à
25 ans vous avez fait votre vie et image
de vous même et vous aider beaucoup la
jeunesse autour de vous on va découvrir
pourquoi plus tard et puis à vos côtés
vous avez amira vous touche
l'ex président de fondations plus bas
tenir très importante le bien connu ici
hormis les maghrébins bonjour alors
l'applaudît la douzaine
mc nous animateur à radio de radio à
média maghreb mais il a du métier pour y
est pratiquement faire cette émission un
tout seul d'ailleurs tellement vous
parlez je vais pas vous prendre votre
place quand même
bah écoute et peut-être que dans
l'avenir vous le fais moi un jour froid
que je prenne ma retraite je parte
alors vous êtes déjà vous avez fait ce
métier là mais en plus vous faites bien
d'autres choses également tout à fait
alors on vous applaudit une nouvelle
fois c'est pourquoi tout le monde ici
portent plus qu'un chapeau alors ce sera
à vous de nous montrer les autres
chapeaux que vous portez d'accord et
puis elle a failli être candidate du
parti libéral dans un comté important
elle a perdu il ya quelques jours mais
c'était par rapport à un ami un collègue
c'est ça donc ça s'est fait en toute
amitié voilà j'ai vu une vieille photo
de vous vous étiez toujours très belle
et jeune à l'époque plus de temps encore
c'est en cinq ans la wii 2013
six candidates dans le comté de corconne
la ville
et puis est-ce que vous avez
actuellement attaché politique pour le
maire de pierrefonds roxboro
alors c'est que vous avez ce désir de
faire de la politique
vous en faites un petit peu parce que
vous êtes responsable des politiciens
autour de vous est ce qu'un jour vous
allez finalement avoir cette chance de
représenter non seulement deux
communautés mais les québécois voulaient
tout le monde est effectivement je suis
né à montréal donc montréalaise de
souche j'aimerais dire mais aussi on est
tous on a tous un peut-être pour
certains on est né où on a des parents
qui sont d'origine moi même ma mère est
française mon père est libanais donc je
suis canadienne mais aussi de
différentes origines
adel c'est vous qui avez choisi les gens
autour de la table
1 vous nous rendez toujours ce service
fanta c'est parce que vous connaissez
les noms de la communauté qu'est ce
qu'ils ont en commun aujourd'hui ces
jeunes fait ce qu'ils ont en commun moi
je passe toute une année en train de
voir des gens je les analyse puis au
bout d'une année j'ai choisi ces gens là
pour moi ces gens là ils ont quelque
chose à apporter à notre communauté
il incarne le lendemain l'avenir est
réellement réellement j'ai confiance en
eux j'ai choisi les meilleurs qui me
semble qu'ils ont du potentiel
non mais vous le connaissez déjà et
j'espère que je continuerai à faire
cette mission leur d'année en année que
je passerai toute une année en train de
voir des gens autour de moi et que je
choisirais certains mais j'espère de
tout mon coeur que d'ici quelques années
vous grandissez encore et encore et que
vous accomplissez surtout votre mission
votre tâche et que vous soyez pour votre
communauté
pour le québec et pour le cas de la
caddel on vous laisse merci beaucoup
il est responsable de tout le salon
après tout faudrait pas qu'ils
commencent à tout cas ce autour de nous
je voulais absolument vous parlez à vous
amira vous la politique ça vous
intéresse pas un voulais pas en parler
[Musique]
pas de problème oui c'est tout commence
par la politique alors fait lui une
démonstration on vous regarde
mais c'est réellement il faut être élu
pour pouvoir mettre des choses
en marche et changer pour changer les
choses dans n'importe quel domaine je
pense qu'il qu'il faut commencer par la
politique pour pouvoir faire ça dans ton
domaine aussi l'entrepreneuriat il faut
avoir mettre les lois favorables afin de
permettre des changements dans le milieu
des affaires
tout à fait parlons de bien comment je
suis surpris de vous voir à la
manifestation sur le climat qui a lieu à
fallait passer à quoi 5 rudy si ça doit
vous déranger un peu j'avoue que ça m'a
dérangé un peu mais j'avais j'avais
accepté l'invitation juste avant
d'ajouter une couche c'est ma fête
aujourd'hui c'est vrai je suis invité
juste pour ça merci et oui bien sûr on
pense à la marche qui se passe à côté
est ce que je faisais ce que je voulais
ajouter à ce qu'a dit à ce qu'on dit
hussein est aussi ami là c'est que oui
c'est important
les élus ou d'être un élu etc et associe
donc également mais d'autres encore plus
c'est important d'avoir de réussir à
mettre le faire le poids en fait donc un
pouce et nos idées vers les élus et
pourquoi je parle de ça parce que je
fais partie du conseil des montréalaises
depuis vraiment quelques temps c'est un
conseil consultatif de la ville de
montréal et nous ce qu'on fait c'est
vraiment décrire des avis des rapports
de recherche pour concernant la
situation des femmes à montréal et pour
essayer de justement pousser les élus et
travailler avec eux les aider les aider
à nous qu'à collaborer avec nous pour
faire avancer la situation des femmes à
montréal
donc c'est vraiment je rejoins vraiment
ce qu'a dit ce qu'a dit m et la
travailler main dans la main c'est
vraiment important
sophie ou ferions une bonne politicienne
ou encore une police jan hors norme vous
écouter tout le monde vous ne parlez pas
ben en fait oui effectivement pour être
politicien il faut savoir écouter mais
aussi pouvoir travailler avec les autres
et je pense qu'il faut jamais dire
jamais la politique c'est peut-être un
domaine
veut pas considérer un jeune âge mais
c'est quelque chose qui peut nous amener
aussi à accomplir des projets donc je
pense comme salma a dit il il existe
différents organismes plate forme pour
pouvoir faire avancer nos intérêts et
justement c'est à savoir comment en fait
trouver des endroits où on peut se
retrouver nous mêmes mais aussi de
pouvoir atteindre l'objectif est
justement là il juste par exemple dans
certaines municipalités il existe des
conseils jeunesse où justement les
jeunes peuvent sensibiliser les élus aux
différents enjeux de terrain qui existe
et puis pour qu'on puisse arriver à un
même objectif ensemble
selma elle vous avez travaillez vous
travaillez en accord avec l'équipe de la
mairesse de montréal madame plaint pas
directement
c'est vraiment quand je parle du conseil
des montréalaises justement on est pour
rapidement faire le topo c'est qu'on les
15 membres bénévoles et donc ce qu'on
fait c'est c'est vraiment totalement non
partisan et il faut pas qu'on se conçoit
justement employé de la ville de
montréal c'est vraiment un organe
consultatif de la ville de montréal dont
qui à l'extérieur et qui observe et qui
conseille ya parmi nous des gens qui ont
déjà travaillé avec la mairesse de
montréal lever la main que vous j'ai
participé pendant les élections
municipales avec madame valérie plantes
et je voudrais rebondir aussi sur le
sujet de la manifestation qui se déroule
à l'instant même où on est en train de
parler
je voudrais dire que c'est
c'est comment dirais-je c'est une coop
une noble cause d'un nez en train dans
les gens sont en train de manifester et
je voudrais profiter de l'occasion d'en
sur radio canada international et et
m'adresser directement aux dirigeants de
cette planète et leur dire que il faut
bien il faut bien que les choses
changent il faut bien que il ya de la
dia delà de l'amélioration se fasse
maintenant parce qu'on on est à bout tu
as comment dire ce qu'on m'a dit la
jeune activiste pour la jeune activiste
greta la jeune activiste greta les
générations futures ne vous oublierons
jamais ça si vous n'agissez pas
maintenant je veux pas embêter personne
ne sait greta qui est venu nous
rencontrer il a manifesté avec nous je
pensais à nantes recherchant des gars
qui l'y a offert son auto électrique
elle a été d'accord parce qu'elle veut
se déplacer sans à créer de nouveaux
problèmes et autour d' attaquer ce que
vous avez fait récemment pour la pour
l'environnement on va faire le tour est
ce qu'on peut le faire sans vous sans
vous ambarès je vais rien faire
justement ce matin j'étais dans une
école locale ici foxborough où il y
avait une initiative pour justement
ramasser les déchets sur les berges de
pierrefonds donc je pense effectivement
c'est on peut dire qu'on n'était pas à
la marche aujourd'hui mais on a quand
même c'est important de faire des
actions à tous les jours et puis c'est
une action continue c'est pas juste sur
une journée et je pense effectivement il
ya toutes sortes d'initiatives locales
où les gens peuvent justement
s'impliquer et puis ça commence chez soi
mais aussi dans notre communauté
olsen vous passez votre tour on va
revenir on va demander à amira qu'est-ce
que vous avez faible de bons pour
l'environnement récemment
je vais rebondir sur ce que je fais qui
est ma vraie qu'elles sont plus là le
preneur je suis co fondatrice d'une
compagnie qui s'appelle bridgeurs et
puis nous confesser qu'on aide les
entreprises manufacturières et
industriels qu'on parle d'environnement
c'est sûr qu'on va aller parler de ce
genre de personne à identifier le type
de technologie d'antisant besoin pour
faire leur transformation digitale et
puis ce qu'on a fait avec bridge elle
sait que de plus en plus on ajoute ce
volet de transition énergétique pour
dire aux entreprises qui tord vous
transformez on peut faire ça en prenant
en considération des technologies qui
permettraient de la réduction de
démission de réduction des déchets de la
réduction de beaucoup de choses tout en
augmentant la productivité
donc je pense que comme l'a dit sophie
la marche trouve ça vraiment génial
j'aurais vraiment aimé aimé y être
aujourd'hui c'est des moments qui sont
importants pour envoyer des messages
unis mais c'est sûr que le travail doit
se faire en profondeur et puis dans
toutes les différentes sphères
d'activités il ya des choses vraiment à
faire chez nous personnellement mais
aussi avec toutes les différentes
personnes qui nous on essaie de faire ça
avec bridgeurs c'est notre activité
principale et on se dit autant aidés
dans le bon sens va falloir épeler sa
semoule bridgeurs idées d'accord mais en
fait on a enlevé le pian n'a mis que 1
er 6f bridgeurs pourquoi pas ce qu'on
construit un pont entre les entreprises
manufacturières et industriels donc
c'est vraiment toute la chaîne de valeur
et la technologie dont ils ont besoin
dans qu'est ce que j'ai besoin d'un
robot j'ai besoin de d'une technologie
verte est ce que j'ai besoin de réalité
augmentée enfin plus ce genre de mots on
entend beaucoup intelligence
artificielle à montréal donc est-ce que
j'ai besoin de ça de quoi j'ai besoin
et puis qui est la personne la plus à
même de répondre à mon besoin en me
fournissant je vous pose et je vais tofu
je revienne à la question initiale
sinon ça n'a aucun sens je ne veux pas
sauter à une autre question qu'est ce
que vous avez fait bon pour
l'environnement les hommes
j'arrive à vélo non mais plus
sérieusement effectivement mes actions
au quotidien je pense je rejoins ce
cadet ce qu'a dit sophie c'est c'est
vraiment qu'est ce qu'on fait au
quotidien oui c'est bien les de lancer
des appels forts comme la marche pour le
climat mais également qu'est ce qu'on
fait au quotidien passé c'est tout bête
je suis descendu j'ai pris mon vélo j'ai
pris mon casque et je me suis dit ah je
vais arriver ici j'aurais très envie
d'un café et je suis remonté pour
prendre ma tasse réutilisable c'est tout
bête mais on y pense
moi j'y pense vraiment rarement et et à
côté de ça j'avoue que j'ai diminuer ma
consommation de viande de 90% de vue que
c'est arrivé au québec et je sais que
c'est pas possible dans tous les pays
parce qu'à chaque fois que je je repars
au maroc par exemple donc d'où je suis
originaire ben là je mange de la viande
et ben déjà à ma mère elle comprendrait
pas et et à côté de ça c'est vraiment je
veux pas faire justement la personne qui
donne les grandes des grandes lois des
grandes leçons exactement merci mais
vraiment si un autre un autre niveau
on peut agir pourquoi ne pas le faire
pour moi c'était vraiment très très
simple de diminuer ma consommation de
viande et comme je vous ai dit je n'en
fais je ne cuisine pas à la maison
et quand je vais au maroc jean prend
malheureusement mais je me sens en très
bonne santé je fais beaucoup de sport et
tout va bien
c'est fantastique moi aussi j'avais
beaucoup de lui mais un peu moins c'est
ainsi parce que j'habite à l'afld à la
ferme à la campagne et pour venir au
travail j'ai une auto électrique et mon
auto électrique est alimenté par des
panneaux solaires
alors je consomme quand même un peu
d'électricité l'hiver pour chauffer la
maison mais je suis sur le point de
changer ça je chauffe et un petit peu
plus haut au hautbois qui pousse sur la
ferme
je peux vous donner de leçons n'ont plus
leurs prix sonné mais ce qui
m'impressionne c'est lui à côté de vous
ah ouais on lui a pas parlé beaucoup un
nom mais la pression parce que son nom
sécu scène maintenant moore et dames
reda je suis perdue des affaires c'est
sartre est très gentil alors vous vous
êtes quelqu'un qui en principe si on
voyait une photo de vous j'en ai vu des
photos de vous les gens qui soient sur
la russe qui vous reconnaissent des fois
ben pour les fans de soccer bien
évidemment des fois ils peuvent me
reconnaître vu que j'ai joué à l'impact
de - ouais ouais non arrive souvent
c'est la question non s'agirait pas que
ça arrive souvent parce que je suis plus
avec l'impact de club après cinq ans
mais c'est sûr qu'au moment où je jouais
avec l'impact ça arrive est pratiquement
à chaque jour où quelqu'un va me donner
un commentaire tout simplement pour me
motiver pour m'encourager ou pour
simplement donner des mots
d'encouragement par rapport à un match
qu'ils sont bien parce que reda ce qui
est extraite exceptionnelle chez vous si
vous avez refait votre vie à 20 ans 25
25 ans moi j'avais 25 ans non 28 28
oui obama 12h25 j'ai l'air plus jeune
ruiz
alors vous avez fait votre vie et les
gens qui refont leur vie en général ils
ont 40 45 ans 50 ans et plus vous l'avez
fait très jeune en disant tout le monde
a cette image de moi comme footballeur
j'ai beaucoup de succès j'ai eu beaucoup
de succès mais je veux plus dans la vie
je veux donner je donnais plus jeu -
recevoir peut-être il y avait peut-être
ça vous on peut dire ce qui s'est passé
en fait c'est que le monde du sport
professionnel c'est tellement exigeant
et ce qui m'est arrivé c'est que entre
en 18 ans où j'ai commencé à jouer
professionnellement et 25 ans j'ai
beaucoup évolué en tant que personne et
il y avait des choses que je remarquais
dans ce monde là qui me plaisait un peu
moins comme le fait par exemple qui ont
prévilégié pas le côté humain on était
vu comme des chiffres comme j'expliquais
amira tout alla donc si on était blessé
l'entourage de l'équipe nous parle un
peu moins ils nous disent ils sont enfin
peu moins pour nous alors quand on
commença à marquer des but par exemple
le matin on va nous saluer on va être
aux petits soins avec nous et se cote
cette hypocrisie l'ag mais pas trop ça
et j'ai remarqué que c'était tout
simplement
c'est ce que le métier demande si on
veut et je me suis dit que ça
m'intéressait plus le matin quand je me
réveille pour aller aux entraînements je
n'avais plus la même motivation j'avais
plus le même le même feu pour aller
m'entraîner et c'est tellement exigeant
que tu peux pas être à cent à 60% à 80%
si t'es pas à 100% ça c'est rien de le
faire et donc j'ai pris la décision tout
simplement de changer de carrière et ce
qui est bien aussi c'est que ce qui a
facilité ce choix c'est que j'ai vécu
certaines expériences marquantes dans ma
vie dans le sport j'ai pu jouer contre
mes joueurs préférés j'ai pu jouer dans
des stades de 65000 personnes j'ai fait
des compétitions un peu partout dans le
monde
donc tout ça ça a été des des choses
positives que j'ai pris de ce parcours
là et ça a été plus facile pour moi de
prendre ces décisions là deux de
regarder autre chose parce que j'avais
déjà expérimenté ce rêve là que j'avais
depuis 81 alors parlons de cette autre
chose parce que vous donnez maintenant
vous donner beaucoup à aux gens qui sont
plus jeunes et qui sont peut-être pas
tout à fait outillés où ils n'ont pas
reçu toutes les
les bienfaits du bon dieu il aura manqué
des choses et vous cessiez de palier en
fait ce qui s'est passé il ya trois ans
j'ai commencé à faire des conférences et
j'ai vraiment aimé ça parce que je vois
l'impact que ça avait chez les jeunes et
quand je repense à mon parcours moi
quand j'avais 13 14 ans c'est à ce
moment là que je me suis dit je veux
devenir joueur de soccer professionnel
mais j'ai jamais rencontré une personne
sur laquelle je peux m'identifier
ça veut dire quelqu'un qui me ressemble
un marocain ou un maghrébin ont peu
importe qui joue au soccer à l'impact de
montréal donc il y avait personne sur
qui je peux - m'identifier donc j'ai un
peu fait ce parcours là tout seul mais
là maintenant je veux être la personne
sur laquelle ces jeunes là peuvent
s'identifier pour croire en leurs rêves
tout simplement il ça peut être en lien
avec le sourire mais ça peut être en
lien avec il avait parti une compagnie
oui ça c'est un côté c'est un côté pas
en parallèle disons l'entrepreneuriat
oui j'ai commencé une campagne de
recrutement dans le domaine du pays
mais ça c'est pour on va dire oui gagner
ma vie mais en même temps nous rire ce
le la compétition qui me manquait dans
le que j'avais plus parce que jouer au
soccer est aussi avoir des ambitions
entrepreneur est tout simplement
mais le côté conférence est plus un
impact que je veux avoir chez ces jeunes
là parce que quand après chaque
conférence pour les gens qui me
connaissent après chaque conférence ça
prend vraiment quelques heures avant de
revenir à moi même parce que c'est des
émotions qui sont tellement spécial que
m que ces gens je vais en refaire en
référence et là ça fait trois ans que
l'on fait reda est très proche de ses
émotions
oui m et sa faible ne déséquilibre pas
on le sent pas dans sa voix qu'il est
déséquilibré et vous avez vous savez où
le centre se trouve pour vous oui ça
l'est où ça se trouve c'est fantastique
ce 100% il faut le savoir il faut savoir
et ça ça vient du monde du saut car
parce que dans 1
un environnement où tu doit performer à
100% à chaque match tu dois savoir te
recentrer de concentrer sur ce qui est
important parce que quand j'ai joué plus
jeunes dans une équipe un peu plus
récréative y avait pas de pression mais
une fois que tu rends dans le monde
professionnel
t'as pas le droit à l'erreur tout
simplement à chaque match était là c'est
ton métier donc tu es là pour performer
tu vas le savoir c'est que tu performes
pavie l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est de
parler de vous ça va jusqu'à maintenant
pas de soucis qui n'a pas assez parlé de
lui-même c'est largement suffisant
écoutez j'ai un projet pour nous tout
cela on dire un peu sur ce que personne
n'a dit par rapport à l'émotion et puis
l'impact qu'on peut avoir auprès des
jeunes je pense effectivement nous en
tant que mijotent les jeunes et ils sont
un peu différentes de nous aujourd'hui
mais je pense effectivement c'est très
important d'avoir dans tous les milieux
d'ailleurs dans tous les domaines
des personnes qui on peut s'identifier
on parle souvent dans le cinéma
les arabes en général n'ont pas
nécessairement des stars ou des idoles
ou la représentation des arabes n'est
pas nécessairement
à son meilleur actuellement mais je
pense si je parlais aussi un peu de mes
expériences personnelles où j'ai senti
un peu cet impact là que je pouvais
avoir auprès des jeunes s'étaient
récemment justement durant ma campagne
pour briguer l'investiture au parti
libéral de pierrefonds roxboro
j'étais allé à la rencontre de jeunes
dans un camp de jour et qui était assez
dominé par les jeunes filles et puis
justement c'est sûr que la politique
c'est pas un domaine dans lequel on voit
beaucoup des femmes ou encore moins des
jeunes et donc
je dois dire que j'étais peut-être
accueilli comme presque une star de sacs
et mais justement et je pense en fait
c'est je pense était une des meilleures
des meilleures expériences parce que
justement le monde et à l'innocence des
enfants mais aussi le fait qu' ils
peuvent se dire ok moi maman un jour
j'aimerais bien aussi être premier
ministre ou député ou quoi que ce soit
et puis justement pouvoir leur donner
cet espoir que tout est possible si on
veut vraiment y arriver et même si on
n'y arrive pas au moment où on veut pas
il faut toujours continuer à essayer
wiesen vous au nom vous un nom les i là
où ça ne veut pas ça souvent à parler au
micro alors une scène vous portez plus
qu'un chapeau en plus de la radio il ya
des choses très sérieuses que vous
faites des changes est sérieux c'est à
dire des choses qui vont vous mener à
des pas importants plus tard dans votre
vie je pense je me sens car ça comme ça
là vous partez avec le ballon alors moi
ça fait pour revenir pour cadrer un peu
je suis ça fait cinq ans que je suis là
je suis d'origine tunisienne
ça fait cinq ans que je suis au canada
j'ai fait un océan juridique
j'ai fait aussi j'ai étudié là j'ai
étudié en droit je fais un bac en droit
entre temps je suis animateur radio à
média maghreb 104.5 fm 14,50 m
à montréal est aussi je suis activistes
on va dire activistes politiques
je me définis comme activiste politique
plus je suis j'ai eu une expérience ici
au canada avec madame valérie plantes
pour les municipalités comme je vous l
ai dit tout à l'heure
et là c'est ce mois ci je participe à
dans les élections tunisiennes avec le
parti ettahrir tounes pour les élections
tunisiennes qui se passe les élections
présidentielles qui sont passés déjà ça
fait deux semaines et il ya les
législatives qui se passe dans deux
semaines alors aussi j'invite les gens à
aller pour voter et un bureau de vote
ici à montréal et un autre à ottawa et
ce parti est ce que moi je connais rien
la politique
ce parti est ce qu'il est proche ou des
couleurs du parti libéral
oui de ce film moi je vois que c'est un
portier qui est plus qu il ya une
démarche libéral une vision libérale de
l'économie
qu'est ce que je vais dire là dedans
mais je pense que les gens déjà
connaissent c'est un parti de le chef du
ce et le chef du gouvernement qui est le
chef du parti c'est monsieur youssef
chef
il ya aussi en les élections on n'a pas
gagné dans les élections présidentielles
on est devenus quatrième puisque la
démocratie en tunisien et c'est rare de
trouver ça dans des paix maintenant
parce que normalement il ya ni le
ministre de la défense ni le ministre
l'ancien le ministre actuel premier
ministre actuel ni un ancien président
qui est dans les deux premiers qui est
passé au deuxième tour c'est une autre
personne ces deux personnes qui sans
gens qui n'ont jamais fait de la
politique qui en qu'il n'était même pas
dans le sphère politique
auparavant un des deux c'est un
propriétaire de chaînes télévision mais
le deuxième c'est une personne qui
serait un professeur universitaire vu
que vous êtes quand même assez jeune con
physiquement quand vous voyez ce que ça
peut arriver quand vous donne quand vous
a comme moindre crédibilité vu que vous
êtes plus jeunes dans un nazi ou là
pourra commencer par les farc je pense
que je suis plus vieux que tu as
l'habitude de voir des gens
effectivement moi j'ai tout essayé pour
avoir l'air plus vieille que mon âge
mais ça ne marche pas je pense
effectivement c'est malheureux mais
effectivement il y a
les gens ont tendance à pas
nécessairement dire ah oui tout qu'est
ce que t'en sais de la politique encore
plus une femme
mais la politique ce n'est pas un
domaine pour toi j'ai fait j'ai eu droit
à toutes sortes de commentaires
malheureusement là on pense qu'on vit
dans un monde assez libérale mais même
au canada parfois on fait face à des
gens qui sont un peu résistants à ces
idées là mais par contre je pense que en
tout cas pour moi personnellement ça m'a
toujours
c'est ce genre de commentaire là qui m'a
toujours comment quoi motiver juste et
bon effectivement et puis je pense aussi
que quelque chose que je disais durant
ma campagne c'est que il faut qu'il ait
une diversité je veux dire le parlement
canadien doit représenter la population
et puis quand on voit des manifestations
comme aujourd'hui c'est justement pour
montrer que les jeunes ils sont
peut-être pas assez sur les dents les
tables de décision mais ils ont aussi un
mot à dire et puis les politiques en
flocons on comprend aujourd'hui ont un
impact sur sur les générations futures
donc je pense que c'est il faut pas se
laisser abattre et pigeons ainsi dans
tous les domaines comme sa province dans
le sport aussi que même en
entrepreneuriat en général c'est je
pense un peu partout on a des remarques
de as tu es jeune tu sais pas c'est pas
de quoi tu parles et genre de choses
mais
mais oui ça motive en même temps et puis
de toutes les façons on n'a pas le choix
on a l'âge qu'on a et on est si on veut
faire quelque chose obligé de se battre
pour répondre à ta question moi
contrairement à ce que les gens pensent
moi je pense que c'est un atout d'être
jeune et de pouvoir se tromper et avoir
des idées changé d'idée et avoir plus
regardé plusieurs visions des choses et
un certain âge on aura assez de maturité
pour même un certain âge on peut avoir
une certaine maturité avec l'expérience
là elle c'est l'expérience qui est qui
qui fait qu' on peut choisir et on peut
avancer dans la politique et je pense
que pour une personne qui commence par
exemple la moi j'ai 25 ans qui commence
à moi moi j'ai commencé à 14 ans à faire
à être dans la société civile à être
dans de faire du bénévolat et j'en fais
encore pour voir les choses en tunisie
est là au canada depuis cinq ans que je
suis venu ici je pense que tout ça peut
me permettre d'avoir une idée un âge
moins que
d'autres personnes qui commencent la
politique à 40 ans il n'est jamais trop
tard il n'est jamais trop tôt pour qui à
l'heure il est encore trop tôt
14h57 êtes sérieux il ya pas de souci
c'est cette émission dure au moins 45
minutes vous ennuyer à vous vous ennuyez
non je m'ennuie pas mais ce que je
voulais être sûr de vous poser ma
prochaine question parce que j'avais
fait une promesse avec aamir à ne pas
parler politique aujourd'hui
et puis là je pense que c'est raté mais
je vais a fait la promesse de lui
demander de lui poser cette question est
la seule qui ait prévenu les autres vous
êtes un peu prise au dépourvu je lui ai
demandé l'autre jour imaginez une
entreprise que vous aimeriez créer un
projet fantastique quelque chose qu'ils
demandent c'est du brainstorming c'est
un on y va avec les îles et qu'on veut
et vous allez chercher qui pour créer
cette entreprise de l'avenir bien sûr ça
pourrait être un environnement ça
pourrait être dans la khl dans la
culture non vous pouvez tous répondre
mais on peut commencer par vous vous
améliorez le projet vous allez chercher
subventions mais c'est c'est drôle parce
que c'est un peu ce que j'ai fait avec
avec b2 en fait donc juste pour savoir
chaud au canada depuis à 2012
je suis venu pour faire une maîtrise
après un diplôme de génie en
informatique
et puis en finissant là la question la
composent à tout le monde tu rends tu
restes tu fais quoi
et puis ça a été une des raisons pour
laquelle je dis ok on va en avait une
problématique puis lancer une compagnie
me permettez de de pouvoir bouger et
puis de de travailler comme on veut puis
moi je suis allé chercher mon co
fondateur qui s'appelle mehdi et qui
n'est sûrement pas en train de regarder
cette émission dont je peux parler sur
lui mais en fait qui lui vivait en
france est sûre avec qui on avait
travaillé ensemble sur d'autres projets
quelques années avant puis on s'est
revus après deux ans
on s'est revu en algérie puis j'avais
des écoutes il ya définitivement un
problème à mettre en lien les
entraînements serait non vraiment
beaucoup de problèmes puis je pense
qu'on peut vraiment aider économiquement
à l'industrialisation qui à
l'augmentation de la productivité de ces
entreprises de manière à ce que ça se
passe mieux que les gens travaillent
mieux qu'on aille vers des
environnements plus propre et où est ce
que ça dit de venir au canada et puis de
lancer cette campagne puis c'est ce
qu'il a fait je sais toujours pas
pourquoi mais donc c'est ce qu'il a fait
piché aller le chercher il est là qui ça
fait trois ans et demi qu'on essaye de
da de faire ça et puis d'améliorer les
choses et on fait ça ici mais aussi avec
des compagnies en afrique du nord on a
des fournisseurs sur 22 pays aujourd'hui
quand je pense que comme céder la
technologie c'est la même partout les
entreprises manufacturières industrielle
en descente ou sur des marchés
international aujourd'hui quand tous des
problématiques très très très similaire
et donc quelles que soient où il sent en
est capable de les aider en leur banque
et white fausse cette technologie de là
et puis d'aller chercher un petit peu
les bonnes personnes les bonnes
technologies quelle que soit l 100 il
fait un petit peu d'être migrants de
venir de différents horizons et tout je
pense qu'on a cette facilité à voir le
monde comme un monde plus que juste où
on a grandi où on est et où on dit ok on
a déjà fait le pas donc on va pas on va
pas se limiter à rester là mais a été
travaillée est ce que quelqu'un comme
stéphane guigo du parti libéral bien
connu dans le monde de l'environnement
pourrait faire partie de votre équipe où
il est trop vieux non tout le monde peut
faire partie de l'équipe au final
l'essentiel c'est d'apporter quelque
chose à la table
mais non nous quand ce qu'on regarde
qu'on va chercher des gens c'est
vraiment déjà le pourquoi on est donc en
est une start up
donc il ya de l'instabilité à ya des
hauts et des bas on est en train de
construire quelque chose
puis c'est pas tout le monde qui a envie
de construire est là et quand même
beaucoup de profils qui veulent juste
continuer puis c'est normal on a besoin
de tout donc en cherche des gens qui
veulent construire qui ont à coeur les
valeurs humaines parce que le monde dans
lequel on est le monde industriel c'est
un monde où l'humain est très important
parle de vol de transformation
technologique mais à une vraie
transformation aussi où l'humain est au
coeur de cette transformation qui est
très important où l'humain les valeurs
sont importantes le pourquoi on fait ça
la vision puisqu'on veut faire nous
c'est d'apporter les visions de chacun
puis d'essayer de construire avec ça on
n'est pas obligé d'avoir de vouloir
faire la même chose mais on peut
s'entraider à arriver
seulement je pense que vous ce serait
pas du développement industriel ce
serait du développement humain et vous
êtes déjà là dedans tout à fait qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez faire de plus si
vous êtes ses patrons d'une entreprise
sans vous jouez à la patronne non mais
si vous étiez je peux jouer à la
patronne score non en fait quand
j'écoutais amiral ça m'a vraiment
ramener 10 années en arrière parce que
justement rencontre en envoyant des des
personnes originaires du maghreb ou et
vivant au québec aujourd'hui
ben nécessairement moi ça me ramène à où
j'étais et moi j'étais conditionné avec
mon parcours académique au maroc a
justement aller dans une entreprise et à
travailler en ressources humaines ce que
j'avais une maîtrise en ressources
humaines mais ça remonte à il ya dix ans
et à un moment je me suis vraiment
écouté parce que c'était fall on a
beaucoup parlé d' engagement au
téléphone comment préparez également ce
cette émission est l'idée c'était à quel
moment pourquoi tu t'engages à quel
moment tu va finalement franchi le pas
et c'est ce moment là où j'étais face à
mon ordinateur dans une entreprise où
tout le monde me disait ne bouge pas
fait ta carrière ici tu tu vas continuer
ne réfléchit pas finalement vraiment
continues tu as enfin trouvé sa place et
là je me suis dit mais seulement écoute
toi est ce que tu penses que toi c'est
ta place c'était très reposant vraiment
je pouvais faire toute ma carrière
là-bas et finalement je me suis écouté
et j'ai quitté cette entreprise
au bout de quelques mois et je suis allé
dans le milieu communautaire donc à
casablanca au maroc et j'ai travaillé
dans une petite association qui défend
les droits des enfants en situation de
rue donc toujours à casablanca qui
existe toujours d'ailleurs ça s'appelle
bay ticket ma maison et depuis c'est
vraiment l'humain qui est au coeur de
mai de mes préoccupations est de mes
engagements
c'est à dire que juste après ce que j'ai
fait c'est que j'ai postulé pour être
journaliste je me suis dit journaliste
j'aime les gens je sais écrire
allez on va mixer ça naïvement je me
suis dit ça
et finalement c'est ce que j'ai fait et
pendant trois ans c'est ce que je leur
ai dit en entretien d'embauché ça va
marcher
donc j'ai écrit dans la rubrique société
alors que tout le monde me disait non
mais ton cv dit que tu dois écrire en
économie tu dois écrire en économie et
cette histoire m'a suivi vraiment
longtemps je me suis dit mais entre ce
que je dois faire
est ce que j'ai envie de faire qu'est-ce
que je vais choisir et je me suis dit je
veux écrire en dans la rubrique société
je veux aller vers les gens comprendre
ce qui va pas et le montrer à tous les
lecteurs du travail du journal pour
lequel je travaillais donc tout ça juste
pour dire que aujourd'hui j'ai réussi à
fusionner qui je suis vraiment ce que
j'aime parce que toujours on dire les
chercheurs ils sont ils sont au dessus
de la mêlée et se croient supérieurs et
ils apportent leur savoir moi je sais
vraiment il y en a certains certaines
mai mais vraiment je suis je suis une
chercheuse une chercheuse pardon de
terrain ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment aller vers les personnes qui
vont pas bien et utiliser les outils que
j'ai appris à l'université finalement
pour transmettre leur vécu parce que je
me dis je c'est juste une porte parole
et aller vers les gens justement qui ont
du pouvoir
donc je je je montre sophie mais c'est
vrai et ensuite juste faire l'interface
jouer à l'interface entre les individus
qu'on côtoie au quotidien et les
personnes qui peuvent changer leur
réalité
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai rejoint le
conseil des montréalaises donc en tant
que bénévole et c'est pour ça qu'à côté
également je fais partie du ca de la
fondation paroles de femmes
donc je sais pas si vous connaissez mais
notre
notre objectif c'est de créer des
espaces de parole pour les femmes
racisées et les femmes autochtones donc
dernièrement on a on a organisé un micro
ouvert donc c'est vraiment des moments
où les femmes se sentent se sentent
valorisés les femmes racisées et elles
nous disent merci ou quand on monte sur
scène dit ah je me reconnais dans dans
ton parcours ou merci le hochement de
tête fait que ça confirme qu'on fait pas
ça pour rien et c'est mon moteur au
quotidien est actuellement pour terminer
stéphane je vais pas être très long je
travaille à la table de quartier de
montréal-nord donc j'ai mille vies en
même temps depuis deux semaines et on
est en train d'organiser un forum
citoyen donc vous vous entendez parler
ces derniers temps de montréal nord
comme l'endroit où on a peur d'aller j'y
vais tous les jours tout va bien et est
également l'endroit qu'on oublie ou les
organismes communautaires ne reçoivent
pas beaucoup de de financement donc je
tenais aussi à le dire à l'antenne parce
que ça ça me tient beaucoup à coeur et
et voilà juste dire que c'est possible
de même si on a un cv qui correspond pas
à ce qu'on fait de faire ce qu'on veut
parce qu'à 17 ans est très difficile de
choisir
au lycée parce que moi je vais système
disons français donc j'étais équivalence
et jette mais un peu un peu plus jeunes
de choisir notre orientation
professionnelle
jean n'a qu'à paris vous déjà qu'ils
décèdent d'avoir un employeur donc il
décide d'être de diriger leur avenir par
un c je pense qu'il ya quelque chose en
commun le même si des fois comme vous
nous avez un emploi
pour gagner votre vie en information
technologies de l'information il ya
aussi tout le reste qui fait que vous
êtes capable de faire ce que vous aimez
faire même si je devais gagner votre vie
ça c'est important gagner sa vie c'est
ces mots j'appelle ça un handicap
problème ça nous empêche de faire des
bonds des fois de faire des choses elle
l'a fait est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
d'autre au tour de table qui n'a pas
fini de rebondir qui aiment répondirent
encore un peu plus et qui ont un vrai un
projet d'avenir lever la main s'il le
faut ben oui oui présentement je suis en
train de travailler sur un projet qui me
tient vraiment à coeur avec quatre
autres personnes
et c'est un organisme en fait qui va
venir en aide pour plus jeunes et nous
notre mission c'est de supporter les
jeunes tout simplement puis on veut
intervenir sur il ya trois axes vraiment
qui nous intéresse
le premier s'est on veut créer une
équipe une équipe de conférenciers qui
vont avoir leur parcours un parcours
différents et qu'on va pouvoir envoyer
aux écoles pour qu'il puisse inspirer
ces jeunes-là et ses conférences et ses
conférenciers là ils vont devoir
on va les matchs et avec les écoles dans
lesquelles ils vont faire leur
conférence et pour éviter le problème
que moi j'ai eu quand j'étais au
secondaire
ça veut dire que si on prend l'exemple
de montréal nord on sait comment
maintenant il ya une communauté
maghrébine ya beaucoup d'haïtiens
donc on va essayer de trouver des
conférenciers sur lesquels ces jeunes là
peuvent s'identifier
donc ça c'est encore plus efficace le
deuxième axe c'est sportif et académique
donc au niveau du sport vu que j'ai joué
à l'impact de moi mais je vais
probablement utilisé utiliser profiter
profitez des relations que j'ai à
l'impact durable pour créer des
partenaires avec avec avec le club est
aussi le troisième axe et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est on veut créer
des formations qui sont dédiés qu'aux
parents donc avant 11 il y devient tout
simplement du fait que au jour
d'aujourd'hui si par exemple moi je veux
devenir chauffeur de taxi en exige de
faire des permis particulier des
formations particulières pour avoir ce
permis là alors que pour être parents un
homme une femme
ils ont un enfant et ils sont laissés à
eux mêmes un peu et donc ce qu'on veut
faire c'est vraiment créer des
informations qui peut aider ses parents
ont les outillant avec les différents
problèmes qui peut arriver dans la vie
d'un enfant et ce qui est bien aussi
c'est que quand l'enfant va venir avec
nous il aura un message de la part de
l'organisme
et quand il va aller à la maison il va
avoir un message qui est sensiblement
pareil il va avoir un clash dans ce qui
reçoit comme information et comme ça on
peut s'assurer que l'enfant y va il va
progresser dans les plans de bonnes
conditions
houssen vous avez ça va beaucoup de
créativité je le sens excusez un projet
d'entreprise quelque chose qui vous
ferait vraiment plaisir de créer en fait
par rapport à ça je voudrais dire que je
porte une autre casquette aussi que je
suis vice président de la jeune chambre
tunisienne du québec et on travaille
beaucoup sur le développement entre la
tunisie et le canada sur différents
domaines on a eu l'occasion de faire
déjà sur une année deux missions
commerciales
avec une délégation d'entrepreneurs qui
on est allé en tunisie au mois de
novembre dernier fin novembre dernier
afin de donner les entrepreneurs
québécois et canadiens en tunisie pour
l'heure pour le raf leur faciliter le
milieu tunisien de l'écosystème tue plus
facilement les différents domaines c'est
plus dans la technologie je suis pas je
me suis pas du domaine mais c'est des
gens qui est qui s'intéressent à la
technologie le canada est un pays qui
est développé dans ce sens là et on a
envie de les emmener ces gens ces gens
là afin de donner leur excellent
expertise dans ce domaine pour aux
tunisiens on a eu notre mission aussi au
mois de juin dernier avec une délégation
officielle canadienne québécoise avec la
ministre de la francophonie qui est un
parti aussi avec nous en tunisie afin de
préparer le sommet de la francophonie
qui va se passer en tunisie en 2020
c'est un sommet pour être des pays
francophones et c'est la tunisie qui est
qui qui va se passer en tunisie au mois
de novembre 2020 travaille sur ça aussi
avec l'administration québécoise et
canadienne et aussi avec
l'administration tunisienne pour ce qui
est du privé et de l'état tic aussi
sophie jeu ça que vous avez pas encore
fait ce que vous devez faire dans la vie
nous attendait en fait même si j'ai pas
compris ce que je voulais dire je
continue toujours à travailler dans le
domaine et puis peut-être si je peux
mentionner
au lendemain des élections fédérales de
2015 avec des certaines personnes qui
étaient intéressés on a cofondé un
organisme qui s'appelle lequel le réseau
canadien pour la participation civique
et ans
essentiellement on avait remarqué qu'il
y avait pas beaucoup d'implication
auprès des jeunes et au près aussi de la
communauté arabe de montréal et donc on
a on s'était dit on va créer cet
organisme là pour essayer d'inciter les
gens à participer non seulement dans la
politique mais aussi au sein de leurs
communautés moi je pense s'il ya
peut-être un message qu'on peut tous se
mettre d'accord et peut-être de dire aux
personnes qui nous regardent c'est que
s'impliquer c'est non seulement un
bénéfice personnel qu'on peut ça nous
permet de grandir et de gagner de la
confiance en soi et puis et de sentir
que l'on contribue à notre société d'une
manière ou d'une autre mais aussi de
pouvoir inciter les gens à aussi
s'impliquer pour pouvoir créer des
réseaux parce que justement ces réseaux
là on ne sait jamais si on peut les
utiliser pour créer une entreprise ou
pour un organisme communautaire où les
possibilités d'emploi donc je pense que
souvent c'est les choses qu'on fait sur
le côté à l'extérieur de notre travail
bien que je fais de la politique 24
durant mon
8h05 je suis aussi la politique après ça
coeur donc je pense qu'il ya toujours
des espaces pour pouvoir s'impliquer et
puis on fait partie d'une génération
peut-être qu'il n'est pas satisfaite
avec notre notre emploi et on veut en
donner encore plus pied donner un sens à
notre vie
faire un impact au mur a ajouté que je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi moi
je suis entrepreneur mais je fais
énormément de choses à côté je suis sur
le conseil d'administration du cdr qui
est le conseil de développement canada
algériens mais aussi sur le conseil de
la fondation que la va venir
et puis j'ai écrit un livre et à
quelques mois et
et puis en fait je pense que quand on
parle d'un pacte il s'agit de en
attendant ce mois je mens me l'a dit on
l'a dit écoutez entrepreneurs talentueux
focus juste sur sapiens ne fait rien
d'autre
et puis j'adore ce que je fais on a un
réel impact sur le sur l'économie puis
je le dis là je vais en profiter si vous
êtes une entreprise manufacturière venez
nous voir on peut vraiment aider mais en
même temps je suis je suis une personne
qui a besoin de faire beaucoup de choses
pour en fait pouvoir avancer et je pense
que quand on a le message que j'aimerais
donner c'est s'il ya quelque chose que
vous voulez faire ou que qui vous
déplaît ou que vous sur lequel vous avez
envie d'avoir un impact il faut pas
hésiter c'est pas vrai qu'une chose
empêche l'autre la preuve j'ai lancé une
entreprise j'écris un livre en même
temps puis je fais aussi plein d'autres
choses à côté et c'est vraiment une
question de
qu'est ce qu'on a envie de faire et
jusqu'où on va aller qu'il faut laisser
personne nous dire qu'on n'est pas
capable faut essayer puis ça marche pas
et a plein d'autres choses que j'ai
essayé père qui un battement occasionnée
et donc ça marche pas tout le temps mais
au moins on essaie et puis on est une
génération qui a cette facilité je pense
en a en a la chance de pouvoir changer
de cap de pouvoir changer sa vie à 25
ans à 30 ans à 45 ans à à l'âge qu'on
veut on a les outils autour de nous on
est dans un pays quand même qui nous
donne cette opportunité de pouvoir aller
chercher des ressources
donc en fait c'est plus il faut les
utiliser il faut pas avoir peur faut les
utiliser puis il faut ne pas en madih
très jeune on ma dit faut pas
sous-estimer le pouvoir du mot aider en
attendant à dire à candide et ça fait
pas gagner de l'argent ça fait pas a
alors que n'importe qui quand on va en
les demandes y écoute j'ai envie de
faire ça j'ai besoin d'être dans ça
c'est très très rare que les personnes
vont dire non je n'ai pas t'aider
bon alors il ya un mot de la fin ici qui
vous appartient un tout petit mouvement
donc pour juste compléter ce que vous
avez dit c'est justement on dise
toujours mais comment tu trouves le
temps et on doit vous le dire à tous les
quatre certainement et je voulais juste
dire que quand on s'implique de manière
bénévole
on peut donner deux heures par semaine
on peut donner deux heures par mois peu
importe mais l'essentiel c'est qu'on
sait qu'on donne et est justement dans
des actions qui nous ressemble et moi je
trouve ça vraiment important de pas
juste si on n'aime pas les chats on va
pas là et spécial ça sert absolument à
rien je veux dire si on n'aime pas les
animaux on va pas là mais vraiment aller
dans un endroit qui aussi ça nous
apporte quelque chose parce que c'est
quand ça nous apporte qu'on apporte
encore plus c'est qu'on est encore plus
stimulée d'aller d'aller faire du
visible vous écoutez tous je vais poser
une question a vu comme un avocat je
pense toujours des questions auxquelles
j'ai déjà les réponses monsieur le juge
quelle heure est il 16h16 ah là là j'ai
dépassé s'est imposée moi non j'ai trop
parlé moi même et non pas vous écoutez
merci beaucoup
alors on va vous applaudir à tour de
rôle a encore une fois j'y tiens
d'accord parce que personne pour vous
applaudir la vie a personne pour nous
applaudir n'est ce pas il ya des gens
aujourd'hui
alors vous avez certainement établi des
contacts entre vous aujourd'hui
peut-être que quelqu'un parmi vous que
vous allez embaucher un jour parce que
vous l'avez rencontré ici faudra nous
écrirons alors merci beaucoup à celle
matane auch bennani était avec ew la
tête et puis à reda agourram également
et puis merci beaucoup à houssen mac do
remercie beaucoup aussi
sophie fantastique d'orage pour des
élections
c'est pas un verdict final on attend
encore c'est cela et puis reda
j'oublierai tenant amir amira
fantastique merci beaucoup d'être venu
également c'est quoi c'est que le nom de
votre votre livre est ce qu'on peut
l'obtenir henry avant le livre s'appelle
la le voyage merveilleux de la sharika
sharika veut dire entreprises en arabe
et en fait c'est un livre qui est dit et
en algérie
aujourd'hui n'est pas encore disponible
ici mais c'est une fable où on a décidé
de donner le mot à l'entreprise d'encana
sharika algérienne pour parler de cette
situation
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et puis
c'est une fois parce qu'en fait appel
aux différents acteurs et que ce
économique en fait parler l'olivier ont
fait parler les jeunes ont fait parler
le quartier ont fait parler donc
différents acteurs comme ça deux ans
fait parler l'anoci de leurs points de
vue sur l'entreprise sur
l'entrepreneuriat qui globalement l'idée
c'est de parler de la situation de
construction du pays qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire ensemble pour aller de
l'avant puis à apporter
une pierre à l'édifice mais un peu
différemment sujet du canada s'est lui
dit du canada avec le professeur taille
praxy hockey et avec aussi les
l'harmonie qui elle est basée en france
donc c'est aussi on est on est un groupe
il a un peu la jeune des trois puis on a
ça faisait un travail de trois ans qui
vient d'un travail sur le modèle
économique et entrepreneuriale de
l'entrepôt d'entreprise en algérie puis
voilà on a fait ça on travaille tout
là-bas en fait tous pleins de choses là
bas
l'aviron va vous réserver la plus chaude
mais la position de plus la
surreprésentation voilà c'est tout je
regarde les trois caméras la fois jeune
et deux yeux c'est compliqué je vais
regarder celle ci je la préfère alors
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui pour cette
émission spéciale de tam-tam canada en
direct du palais des congrès de montréal
mais je dois préciser que on a notre
équipe de la section haram qui s'en
vient faire une émission également en
direct dans quelques instants à i 30
exactement et 30
alors peu importe dans quel pays vous
vous trouvez en principe dans quelques
minutes il sera et 30 sauf bien sûr
quelque part en plusieurs endroits des
airs mais quelque part dans les mairies
thiemo canada c'est différent en tout
cas je ne fais pas de cours de
géographie aujourd'hui j'ai ont fait
beaucoup de politiques c'était suffisant
alors l'équipe s'en vient fadi à rooney
mais abou saab et samir ben jaafer au
sujet de samir il revient de mission
personnelle c'est un journaliste il
était en algérie son pays natal et il a
accordé une entrevue
c'est un aujourd'hui donc ça nous coûte
rien et c'est sur le site de tomtom
canada de cette émission que vous
regarde en ce moment premier item pour
poursuivre la discussion avec nous et la
réflexion sur l'engagement canado
maghrébin c'est là vous regardez et puis
à la semaine prochaine
merci flammes à naples
[Musique]